ladies and gentlemen dear friends
welcome to this uh high level
international donner conference
here in varso i'm yves d'accor i'm your
moderator i'm very pleased to moderate
this event
hosted
by co-hosted by the prime minister from
poland and prime minister from sweden
we're here to mobilize urgently need
support for the ukrainian people
now and of course in the longer term
our conference is broadcast live for
information we do have two aim
one is this high-level donor conference
will primarily serve as an opportunity
for all of us for the international
community
to announce new pledges allocation and
disbursement aim at meeting immediate
united needs
due to the war in ukraine
we also have
a space and we will allow ourselves
discussions on how to support the
resilience of the ukrainian society
and their longer team needs
as you can see we are a lot and i would
like to thank you all to be there we
were a lot here together but we also a
lot here online uh so uh let's make sure
that we take the time to be able to
discuss to explore
to commit together and here as a
moderator i would like to ask you
one thing
be sharp i know that you will be
be also short if you can and i really
would like you to be also straight to
the point we have we are a lot and i
will have to try to moderate that and
being sure that we are able to go
through the day and achieving our our
results
now i would like for the opening remark
uh to end over to the prime minister of
poland please your excellency you have
the floor
thank you very much
um
[Music]
prime minister dear magdalena madam
president
usually
mr president uh charles dear prime
ministers secretaries and commissioners
all distinguished guests and
in particular i'm gonna welcome dennis
as well prime minister of ukraine
thank you very much for being with us
today
i'm so glad to see you many of you in
warsaw and many join us
online
uh all that's such a short notice but
most of all i'm glad that we are united
that this is
one of key messages which we
want to
convey to the external world
and uh critically important message
your presence here shows that we are not
indifferent to suffering causes caused
by this brutal unjust
genocidal war
that we will do everything in our power
to stop russia and to ensure ukrainian
victory
it is a pleasure and honor to host this
conference with madame prime minister
madalana anderson
poland and sweden are long-time friends
and allies 13 years ago we have founded
the eastern partnership and since that
time we have worked hand-in-hand to
develop stable and prosperous
ties between the eu and our eastern
neighborhood
but our partnership has never been as
important as it is today
in the face of
brutal russian aggression
our support for ukraine
has many dimensions including the
political alliance military aid but also
the humanitarian effort
the situation continues to deteriorate
more than a quarter of ukraine's
population has been internally displaced
or forced to leave the country
russian attacks on civilians
murder rape torture refusal to create
safe humanitarian corridors
and force deportations
further worsen the conditions
ukraine uh needs over 12 000 tons of
humanitarian aid every day this is
information which we got from our
ukrainian friends
at the moment only around 3 000 tons are
provided through international efforts
less than 25 percent of the ukrainian
needs
so
more funds for food medicine hygiene
products and other equipment are
urgently needed
i hope that today's conference will
allow us to mobilize those funds it's
it's very very important
we must not forget about the refugees
already over 3 million people mostly
women with children have crossed the
polish border
and they meet
millions of people that opened their
hearts and homes
volunteers
families firemen police officers medical
personnel local and national government
institutions
ngos and many others
over
180 000 tons of humanitarian aid
has been delivered to ukraine uh via
poland
similar efforts were made from many
other countries inspections especially
in central europe and in amongst
scandinavian countries
i want to thank each and every person
that helps ukraine and ukrainian
refugees
and i want to thank all the governments
institutions and organizations for
organizing
support
but the strongest gratitude we owe to
ukraine
and ukrainian people
dear ukrainian sisters and brothers dear
president zowenski their prime minister
mihal dear denis we know very well that
today you are not only fighting for your
homeland
independence and freedom but also for
ours
we will continue to support you in every
possible way
and you will win this war
we will we will win together
together we will demonstrate that
european values are not empty words
but that they are backed with action
thank you very much thank you everyone
for coming here in person and thank you
for all your efforts which you are doing
for ukraine thank you
thank you very much prime minister
i would like now to enter and over to
the other co-host prime minister of
sweden your excellency please
thank you and excellencies ladies and
gentlemen and first of all thank you
very much uh to my colleague matthias
moriyatsky for
co-hosting this conference and the good
cooperation we've had to organize this
conference
and we gather here today in solidarity
with the people of ukraine
a people that is suffering enormous
injustice and great pain
and i would like to begin with a quote
from ilya an 11 year old boy from odessa
i was afraid
he told unicef
there were explosions
and i could hear them very well
and at any time
a rocket could hit the house where i
live
and everybody
would die
and this is just one of many testimonies
but no child should have to go through
this
and after russia's unprovoked and
unjustified lord's great scale
aggression against ukraine europe is no
longer the same
and the testimonies from ukraine remind
us of the worst moments in european
history
a true city atrocities
that we thought no one would have to
experience again
and dear prime minister
smith
let me express my deepest
admiration for the courage of the
ukrainian people
and my heart goes to all ukrainians who
are suffering due to this war
we're very grateful that you're here
with us today and that presidency will
join us virtually and just as my
colleague said ukraine will win this war
and we will stand by your side
today we manifest our collective
solidarity with the people of ukraine
and i'm pleased to co-host this
conference with my colleague and i'm
very happy that together we're able to
take this important initiative and i
also want to thank the president of the
european council search michelle and the
president of the european commission
ursula von relaying for being here today
but also for their leadership in
managing the consequences of this war
and for being our partners in this
conference
i also would like to acknowledge the key
role of the united nations represented
through the under secretary general for
humanitarian affairs martin griffiths
and ukraine is in dire need of
humanitarian and financial support as
well as military equipment
and today at this session we will focus
on the urgent need to mobilize funding
for the humanitarian response in ukraine
and the revised u.n appeal amounts to
2.22 million billion us dollar
sweden will today provide an additional
23 u.s
million u.s dollar to support
humanitarian actors in ukraine
in this context i would also like to
express my admin administ admiration for
our co-host in poland
and the polish people for their
extraordinary solidarity with millions
of ukrainians who have fled their homes
and also the leading role that you have
taken in supporting ukraine in different
perspectives
since the russian invasion of ukraine
international partners have worked hard
to expand their operations much has been
achieved but much work remains
and the humanitarian system needs our
continued support and here the um plays
an essential role in coordinating the
humanitarian response
and i would like to pay tribute to all
those who tirelessly work to deliver
life-saving assistance in very
challenging enviro conditions and
environments
the war is far from over but we must
prepare for when it is so we need to
look beyond immediate humanitarian
support and lay the groundwork for the
recovery of ukraine
life-saving systems
assistance must be coupled with efforts
to safeguard a brighter future for the
ukrainian people creating a bridge
between the urgent humanitarian
operations and the long-term solutions
for ukraine
and together with ukrainian government
we need to find ways to support and
strengthen the resilience of the
ukrainian society
and today will be an opportunity for us
to discuss how the international
community can help address ukraine's
current economic challenges created by
the war and present concrete financing
solution
and while we meet here in solidarity we
cannot forget the fundamental issue
russia must end its aggression against
ukraine there is easy solution
they could just stop the war and go back
home
international law must be respected and
we will
work to bring the responsible for the
russian crimes in ukraine to justice
justice
and let me end here where i started with
ilya from odessa and the millions of
ukrainians in need of support
with today's conference we are sending a
clear signal that we continue to stand
with them thank you
thank you
thank you very much prime minister
anderson and i would like to uh to bring
in from keith uh president zelensky
life president
please
welcome we are very happy to uh to
receive us here at that conference
president you have the floor
dear ladies and gentlemen
full-scale russian war
against ukraine our meeting in this
format and with such an objective proves
that
ukraine europe and the whole world
are on the way to our joint victory our
country retains full functionality
our continent is united millions and
millions of people around the world
support us
so that the tyranny would lose
the armed forces of ukraine
and all of our heroic defenders bravely
and firmly defend our freedom on the
battlefield
but how this brutal war will end
is decided not only on the battlefield
there is also the economy and finance
humanitarian support
and the ability to ensure normal life
on liberated territories and rebuilding
what was destroyed by the russian army
freedom must demonstrate
that it protects and provides the people
better than tyranny
which for decades has enjoyed massive
flow of money
for oil gas and other raw material sales
[Music]
that's how
freedom wins that is why this conference
is so important for everyone in europe
both strategically and tactically
first
we need
sufficient financial resources so that
ukrainian men and women would be
provided with everything they need while
the war continues the ukrainian state as
the manager of these funds will cover
all urgent needs both defensive
social and humanitarian second
we are already preparing a large-scale
recovery and rebuilding plan for ukraine
after the war and we need a strategic
international support plan for ukraine
that will be a modern analog of the
historic marshall plan it is money
technology professionals and gross
opportunities which are required to
return to a safe life
modernization and social development
this will be an investment in the
stability of the whole of central and
eastern europe so the aggressor would
know that he will not break the power of
europe and all three nations all that
everything destroyed by the war would be
rebuilt the restoration of ukraine must
now become the same historical example
for our time and future
as the
restoration of european countries after
the second world war
and such
free world investments
should they be quick and
sufficient
will mean that millions of ukrainians
who have been displaced by the war
would be able to return home
[Music]
we offer our partners the
civilized and responsible countries to
take patronage over those regions cities
and industries of ukraine that have
suffered from the war unleashed by
russia to assume patronage so it's to
work with us to ensure the full recovery
of these regions cities and industries
such a patronage project
can create a new
and equally historic
example of interaction and partnership
between the states of the free world
between regions cities and companies of
europe and democratic states
third
ukraine needs to
move quickly to the european union
by acquiring the candidates the status
which must be granted right now under
conditions of war and according to
special shortened procedure that is to
gain this eu membership this war of
russia against ukraine was planned as a
preparation for striking a blow against
the united europe
so more unification would be a powerful
response to all that that is why
ukraine's membership in the european
union must be an absolute reality not
just promises or prospects but practical
steps
i know
we are ready for these steps
and you know it too
i'm sure that most of you clearly
understand this ladies and gentlemen
i'm grateful to poland and sweden to
prime minister matthias morowetsky and
the prime minister
magdalena anderson for hosting
this
high-level donor conference this year
i'm grateful to the president of the
european council cheryl michelle
and to the president of the european
commission
ursula founder line for their leadership
that makes europe a true defender of
freedom
i'm grateful to all the participants of
the conference for being with us in this
war for a free democratic life for
millions of people not only for ukraine
but for all of us
who
may be threatened by tyranny i believe
that
europe will show its strengths today
you will show your strengths including
the strengths of international
institutions you and institutions whose
representatives
are present with us now
and can be more effective because this
is for our common freedom thank you for
attention glory to ukraine
thank you very much president
i would like to give the floor to the
prime minister of ukraine you have the
floor your excellencies
[Music]
thank you
the mr prime minister of poland matteos
the prime minister of sweden the
magdalena
uh the mr president of the european
council
the
madam
president of the european commission or
somaphone deland their colleagues there
is war in ukraine our losses in terms of
infrastructure economy
people are extremely high
we got more than 600 million dollars of
direct losses more than 5 million of
ukrainians are forced to flee their
homes and go abroad more than 12 million
of ukraine's have been displaced a third
of ukrainian business has stopped we are
now in the european union in poland
so let me tell you this ukrainian army
is fighting now vindia bogas and nasa
ivasha walnuts
and for the victory we need four things
weapon sanctions financing and european
perspective
weapon to defend ukraine and all of
europe from the aggressor sanctions to
stop aggressor for further financing the
war
funding to support our people and our
economy and euro integration because
this is the civilizational
choice of ukrainians today is the
conference of donors so let me speak
more about financing
ukraine together with the partners all
around the world is prepared their
recovery plan and
uh
recall ukraine recovery fund united 24
required
we are planning not just to restore what
was damaged or destroyed by aggressor we
want to build a new european country
starting with the green technologies to
the european standards of construction
from aggro processing to
self-sufficiency in energy sector from
development of defense industries to
climatic modernization from free
european market to the modern
urban spaces
and we are planning to do it right now
and right now we want to be a member of
the european union we need a recognition
in the european family now that is why
we are supporting
our and your freedom we understand that
our goals are ambitious and we believe
that the whole world will help us in
terms of finance legislation creativity
art each of you can contribute to
building a new ukraine a country of
dream this is not an allegory we have
created
a ukraine recovery fund and each of you
can contribute people corporations
countries organizations everyone can do
their part everything will be
transparent deloitte audit reports on
the website everyone will be able to
clearly see everything you 24 go voa
join in
we also are creating a ukraine recovery
plan and we propose every country every
region every city to join in we will
create the parameters for recovery we
will together decide
how the ukrainian cities should look
like and how a ukrainian economy
should work what technologies
what areas will be
of priority how the business should work
what regulations should be used
and then we invite every country every
region every city of the world to
actually contribute to the recovery
a month ago the president of ukraine and
me urged european cities to take
patronage over the damaged
ukrainian sounds
well the result has exceeded
my expectations the uk committed to
support the recovery of the kiev region
denmark uh is patron nikolai greece
odessa so that's a good start
but the rakharkiv sumai and cherniv who
still need your help as well as hundreds
of small towns and villages all around
ukraine and i
know that they will receive this help
for your
freedom and for our freedom be brave
like ukraine glory to ukraine glory to
poland glory to the democratic world
thank you
thank you very much prime minister and
also thank you for for being with us in
person and you will be also at the round
table this afternoon and that will be so
important to discuss in fact long-term
recovery i would like now to give the
floor uh to a president of european
council uh you have uh the floor your
excellency
thank you dear prime minister of ukraine
dear matthias they are my delegates also
dear friends ladies and gentlemen i
would like to thank both magdalena and
matthias for organizing this event here
in poland we have built a massive
solidarity operation hosting more than
three million ukrainian refugees
and acting as a hub to support
ukrainians within ukraine and sweden
their magdalena sweden has always done
more than his share in supporting
refugees and being a steady friend to
ukraine i'd like to personally thank you
and your citizens for that
ladies and gentlemen dear friends
several
weeks ago
with president zlinski we discussed the
idea of a solidarity trust fund to
support ukraine and at our last european
council meeting in march we decided to
create this solidarity fund and this is
a concrete expression of our commitment
to ukraine together with the help and
support of external donors and our
solidarity efforts will focus on three
key areas humanitarian support
short-term liquidity needs and
reconstruction
and we must act now to address the
immediate suffering of the ukrainian
people both in and outside ukraine
that's why priority number one is to
raise money for this humanitarian action
there is another
urgent need this liquidity ukraine needs
significant funding to keep the state
running roughly 5 billion euro per month
according to the imf we have mobilized
and disbursed micro financial assistance
to our friends and together with our
friends and partners but
we must not be complacent we must do
much more to deliver practical support
now immediately to make sure that nurses
doctors teachers can be paid at time and
ukraine and continue to function
and finally i'd like to send a personal
message of hope and encouragement to all
ukrainians to the soldiers
on the ground to all the ukrainians
supporting the war effort and to the
millions who have fled the war and long
for their homes
we will help to rebuild your country and
your economy your homes schools
hospitals businesses
the future of a safe and prosperous
ukraine combined with construction
funding with the necessary reforms and
it's not just a long-term theoretical
vision where construction starts today
difference the cornerstone of our
solidarity trust fund is precisely the
word
trust
we trust ukraine
and our efforts here today reflect this
trust
together we will rebuild a modern
prosperous and democratic ukraine a
country full of confidence and ready to
embrace its european future and its
place in our common european family we
must also make sure that we get the most
out of every euro and the eu is best
placed to support your efforts to link
reconstruction with a reforms that will
transform ukraine and we support ukraine
in its choice of the european path the
people of ukraine talented capable and
hard-working you know best what your
citizens need in your towns and regions
and will be right by your side to offer
practical concrete and operational
expertise and our full support and
that's why we fully embrace presidency's
ambitious vision for a modern
forward-looking ukraine that engages
grassroots leaders and citizens alike
and his concept to partner eu cities and
regions with ukrainian cities and
regions is an excellent idea because it
will breathe new life into areas
traumatized by war
as we approach europe day on may 9th a
day to remember peace and unity
after the house of world war ii
we are also reminded of the martial plan
that helped to revive europe and get
economies back on their feet after the
devastation of war
and today
as we again see the refugees of war on
european soul in ukraine
i believe i firmly believe
the solidarity transfer can be and must
be the starting point of a european
martial plan for this century an engine
of solidarity for the renewal and
reconstruction of ukraine for the
prosperity of europe and for the
transatlantic alliance
ladies and gentlemen
dear prime minister of ukraine the
adonis
allow me to end on a more personal note
during my last visit to ukraine in
borodianja
i visited a small park with the state
view of a famous ukrainian poet
terrace chefchenko
russian soldiers put bullets in the
heads of this statue
they try to execute the ukrainian poet
just like they are trying to execute
ukraine
but they've not succeeded and they will
not succeed the statue is still there
standing proudly a defined symbol
just as ukraine continues to stand
proudly defined and destructible and
breakable and we the eu together with
all our friends we are with you you are
not alone thank you
thank you president michelle and may i
just remember to everybody and i know
it's difficult we have so much to say
but i need you to be to stick to the
time please sorry for the next one we're
following on but that's what happened so
presidents of the european council
commissions you do have the floor your
excellencies please
thank you very much and um i understand
the restricting of the timing so first
of all i really want to thank you
magdalena you matteo
for organizing this and it's wonderful
dennis to have you here with us
i mean dear fellow leaders colleagues
and ladies and gentlemen the brutality
of russia's aggression is shocking the
world
and i've seen it indeed with my own eyes
when i was visiting
kiev
and i went with you
dennis to butcher
to see the mass graves
to see the body bags
to see the scars and wounds in the
houses and hospitals that have been
shelled
the kindergartens the schools
it it is atrocious it is a war crime on
an everyday basis that russia is
committing
and therefore we stand by your side we
cannot match the bravery and the
sacrifice
of the ukrainian people but we can back
you we can help you we can stand by your
side
we can help you with our economic power
on one hand the sanctions yesterday we
unleashed the six package of sanctions
and these sanctions are biting deep
into the russian economy and this is the
purpose of it
putin has to pay a price for this
aggression but second also with economic
power to support you
ten weeks of war since then we have
supported with 4 billion in
economic support financial support
we have mobilized 3.5 billion for the
refugees in the european union but more
important
three weeks ago here in warsaw already
1.8 billion we have pledged for the
internally displaced people in ukraine
but this is not enough this is for sure
and therefore many thanks again for
this pledging conference
i have uh the privilege and the honor to
start with the pledging
and we're happy to pledge 200 million
euros
for the people in ukraine the internally
displaced people in ukraine and i hope
that many many more will follow us
last comment on what i heard from
president zielinski and you dear dennis
as you were asking for practical steps
you're so right
reconstruction full support from our
site
we need indeed a reconstruction as you
said to build a competitive prosperous
you said country of dream
you have us on your side i think if we
manage to have the investment billions
of hundreds of billions of euros
and the reforms this will not only build
your country and you but this will also
pave your way into the european union
slava ukrainia
thank you very much uh mrs president i
would like now to give the four
uh to the unusg for you maintain a fair
emergency coordinator please please you
have the floor
thanks very much indeed thanks uh our
hosts excellencies
ladies and gentlemen thank you
for this opportunity to be here today in
solidarity with the people of ukraine
special thanks of course to the prime
ministers of poland and sweden for
hosting this
and for the strong support to the
humanitarian response from the european
union
and being in warsaw
i thank the people of poland
who so generously have welcomed and
continue to support
an astonishing
wave of refugees from ukraine needing
that support and welcome
when my secretary general antonio
gutierrez visited kiev one week ago he
described ukraine as an epicenter
of unbearable heartache and pain
when i myself visited the capital
a week before and looked down on those
mass graves that we've
been hearing about again today in
bukhara i too came away
as anyone would with an overwhelming
feeling of how in guterres's words how
absurd the war is how senseless the
sense suffering is and how vital it is
that all of us the world steps up
to do everything we can to ease the pain
of those people
just a few days ago
with our friends from the international
committee of the red cross peter is here
with us
together we managed to evacuate over 100
people
but only a hundred people from
the azov style steel plant in mario paul
in our joint operation
and in agreement with the parties to the
conflict
yesterday
with the same partnership and with the
same agreements we escorted out i think
over 340 civilians from around different
parts of mario paul and today
as we speak
the convoy is proceeding
to get to as of style by tomorrow
morning
hopefully
to receive those civilians remaining in
that bleak hell that they have inhabited
for so many weeks and months and take
them back to safety
this
elaborate and dangerous operation
has taken
days and a herculean effort
in coordination advocacy agreements
deployment partnership to achieve
it would have been worth it to save one
person
and we're now trying to do it for more
but it's a sobering reminder of the
difficulties of operation
for the safety
and protection of the civilians of
ukraine how difficult it is even to
achieve these results
in ukraine the lives of ordinary women
men and especially children have been
torn apart and we have seen this the
evidence is in front of us their homes
bombed
families uprooted
often leaving the country separated
killed injured traumatized and we heard
about unicef's evidence of that
the war has caused
the fastest
forced population movement since the
second world war here we are in poland
uh
in witness of it more than 5.6 million
are refugees
and over 7.7 million people are
displaced within ukraine
and many others often the most
vulnerable indeed
have been unable to leave their homes
this includes
older people
the infirm persons with disabilities
nearly 16 million people
need humanitarian aid according to our
latest estimate
about 40 percent of all the ukrainians
left in the country need and deserve
humanitarian aid this is a suffering on
a scale not seen in europe
certainly for my lifetime
united nations and our more than
200 humanitarian partners
have scaled up
and deployed additional staff across the
country we operate now out of eight
designated hubs
outside kiev ardene can i ask you to
conclude please to be quick yeah thank
you
um and we have reached many people from
there
we've launched an emergency appeal
asking for 2.25 billion
um and we hope we will also see some
support for that um
we're here to stay we're all here to
stay we're here to attest to the
solidarity needed by the people of
ukraine and i'm very grateful to the
organizers of this conference the
opportunity to speak thanks a lot
thank you very much martin thank you
and i would like now to uh to give the
floor to the president of the icrc the
international committee of the red cross
please
thanks a lot excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
the level of test destruction and misery
of civilians affected by the
international armed conflict in ukraine
is abhorrent and unacceptable
i thank the prime minister of poland and
sweden to bring us together today to
enhance our
response i am addressing you today as
donors certainly but first and foremost
in your capacity as high contracting
parties to the geneva conventions on the
issues at heart of our mandate the
life-saving impacts of humanitarian
action and international humanitarian
law
importantly
international humanitarian law or use in
bello is about the ways warfare is
conducted it is solely humanitarian
seeking to limit the suffering cost
crucially it is independent from
questions about the justification or
reason of war or use at pelham
the geneva conventions and additional
protocols identify critical issues where
the consensus of the parties is vital to
offer a minimum of humanity and conflict
so that civilians and wounded people are
protected so humanitarian aid can reach
those in need so that prisoners of war
are treated humanely so that people do
not disappear so that mortal remains are
collected in a dignified manner the law
is also clear on the obligations to
respect and ensure respect for
international law including to
facilitate the access of humanitarian
action access is an obligation not a
point of negotiation
the icrc knows the reaching consensual
agreements on
how difficult it is to reaching
consensual agreements on humanitarian
issues
we appreciate the agreements that have
been made by the parties for example in
the safe passage arrangements allowing
people to leave areas of hostilities
such recently in mario paul
martin has mentioned it
progress has been too slow and too
little it has led to senseless death and
prolonged suffering but we have seen the
potential of agreement to be made and we
implore parties to take expanded efforts
to save lives today the generous funding
of humanitarian action for people
impacted by the conflict is critical but
it is only part of the picture to meet
the needs of the civilian populations
funds must be equitably operationalized
for this the space for neutral and
impartial independent humanitarian
action must be protected so that those
in most need can be served without
discrimination and where people are
already present for eight years in
ukraine the icrc works with the
ukrainian red cross society is and is
massively scaling up its response today
our support in places like keith mario
paul odessa don yetz kulhansk and
elsewhere includes emergency assistance
such as food water and essential items
we are supporting hospitals and primary
health care facilities with medical
equipment and emergency preparedness we
are working on mitigating the impact of
weapons contamination and helping repair
damaged water stations and homes
tens of thousands of local red cross and
dry crescent volunteers and staff across
europe are working tirelessly to provide
support to those needs excellencies the
foundations for reconstruction in
ukraine must be laid today to avoid
further humanitarian suffering
service is vital to the survival of the
civilian population water electricity
healthcare must continue maintaining
these services in the coming weeks and
months will avoid the reverberating
secondary impacts and mitigate further
degradation in the longer term
in this way frontline humanitarian
action is a vital stabilizing factor in
a fragmented environment and the
building block towards broader peace
building efforts those living through
the horrors of this conflict need urgent
and pragmatic solutions for now and for
the future i urge you to support
principal humanitarian action to do your
part in championing respect for
international humanitarian law and
action and i thank you
thank you very much and this is now the
end of uh the opening remarks which i
really would like to thank you all it
really set the scene with a special
thanks to president zielinski and prime
minister shimla uh that has been an
extremely important part now we're
moving to uh two different parts we're
now moving to a part where we will hear
some voices from the people directly
affected by the war
and we'll hear some major international
organization talking about that and then
we will transit to the pledging session
but first a video of two minutes about
the situation and about some of the
people affected by war please
[Music]
um
[Music]
thank you very much and i would like now
to give the floor to the un high
commission for refugee filippo grandi
filippo is from
is with us by video conference philippo
greetings can you hear me yes please go
ahead welcome thank you thank you prime
ministers ladies and gentlemen in the 10
weeks since the russian invasion a third
of ukrainians as we've heard already
have been forced from their homes this
is the largest human displacement crisis
in the world today and it is the
displays that are the focus of unhcr's
response and also of my quick remarks
working
under the government's leadership in
ukraine the united nations as we heard
continues to deliver but not just in the
west of the country but increasingly in
the center and east to help also those
who are affected but not yet displaced
unhcr my organization is part of this
effort it has expanded its cash
assistance program for idps and stepped
up emergency shelter support including
collective accommodation we're also
providing targeted protection
counselling psychosocial support and
legal aid but we all of us
must continue to step up and we will
our discussions with ukrainian officials
also revealed
their deep and very justified concern
for the plight of the
5.7 currently million ukrainian refugees
ukraine's neighbors have not only kept
their borders open but have taken a
humane efficient and effective approach
as i've seen myself several times to
sheltering ukrainians they deserve our
praise and gratitude we cannot however
take for granted this exceptional
hospitality the european union and we
heard the commission president speak
about that a few minutes ago has played
continues to play a key role including
by granting temporary protection to
those fleeing ukraine this support must
continue and be expanded as host states
include refugees in health education and
other social services inclusion is the
key challenge until people can return
home
unhcr alongside the rest of the un
family and 140 partners
helps coordinating international
assistance through the refugee response
plan and focusing on key protection
issues
especially for children and women at
risk of trafficking and exploitation
through activities that include cash
assistance information campaigns and
along with unicef the blue dot net
network
please allow me to conclude with four
practical asks
first
step up humanitarian support for
ukrainians wherever they are
fully funded humanitarian appeals are
critical they're not yet fully funded so
that's very important
second
invest
in housing solutions in ukraine for
internally displaced people that provide
decent accommodation for the medium term
not temporary camps this also means cash
programs to expand choices available to
idps including enabling them to find
their own accommodation
third support the ukrainian government
in its efforts to enhance shelter repair
and reconstruction
so that house that refugees and idps can
return home voluntarily and with dignity
when they are ready as president
zelinski just told us
and fourth
reinforce states
hosting refugees
that are actually shouldering the
international community's collective
responsibility for hosting refugees
and finally and most of all and
immediately please
do all you can to end to end this
atrocious war thank you
thank you very much philippo and i would
like now to give the floor uh to the
executive director of the world food
program please
you have the floor david
thank you let me get uh thank you and
i'll get right to the point you've heard
the numbers uh we're reaching about 3.3
million people inside ukraine right now
we hope to scale up to about 4 million
by the end of this month 6 million by
end of next month obviously depending
upon two things access and uh money what
we're trying to do in terms of the hard
to reach areas of course is bring in
kind support but where there is some
degree of supply chain throughout the
rest of ukraine we're trying to bring in
cash-based transfers to put liquidity
into the marketplace to help a very very
serious cash flow problem that they have
as well as we're trying to buy as much
as we can locally to stimulate the local
economy so you know the issues we're all
facing we're reaching as many people as
we can we need to continue to move but
let me hit on one other matter that is
absolutely critical because it impacts
not just ukraine but it impacts the rest
of the world that is if we don't get
those ports open in the odessa region
we're going to have economic
agricultural collapse inside ukraine a
country that feeds 400 million people
and i can tell you the devastation
globally will be beyond anything we have
seen food prices are going up fuel
prices are going up shipping costs are
going up and we are looking at
catastrophe upon catastrophe and we know
what happens when we don't reach people
inside it costs us a hundred times on
the outside we saw that in the syrian
war i know germa germany just did a
study uh the impact is literally over
100 to 200 times more expensively for
those we can't reach on the inside but
if we don't get those ports open because
the silos right now are full
agricultural harvesting for heart for
like wheat etc is to take place in july
and august and where if they do get back
into the fields where they're going to
put that food because the silos are full
why are the silos full because the ports
are blocked why the ports block because
russia has it blocked so we are asking
russia please
please we will have famines around the
world unless we open up those ports and
allow passageway to help people
around the world this is a critical
issue for ukraine and most importantly
it's a critical issue for the rest of
the world over the next eight to 12
months and next year thank you
thank you very much and i would now
would like to give the floor to the
executive director of unicef please go
ahead
thank you very much excellencies and
colleagues and thank you all for your
critical work every day that the war in
ukraine continues is a nightmare for
millions of children nearly two-thirds
of ukraine's children have been forced
to flee many have seen things no child
should ever see
their homes have been bombed their
schools have been attacked along with
all the systems that could help them
survive and we must never forget the
hundreds of children who have not
survived many of them killed by
explosive weapons and hundreds of other
children who have been wounded in this
senseless war
every minute counts in the effort to
help every child affected by the war
reaching them is extremely challenging
especially in parts of eastern ukraine
where shelling and attacks are
continuous
from the very start of the war unicef
has been working wherever children need
us to be from the front lines to the
borders to the country's hosting
refugees we've delivered millions of
dollars worth of emergency supplies to
hospitals shelters train stations
schools and child protection centers and
we have trucked in safe water for over a
million people
and both in ukraine and in neighboring
countries we are operating ongoing child
protection services
education health care and social
protection support we will continue
doing everything we can for ukraine's
children to meet their urgent needs and
also to support critical social services
that build resilience so they'll be able
to rebuild their lives
i wish this was enough it is not only
peace will ever be enough to give these
children even a fraction of what they've
lost children deserve peace
until then we will stay and deliver for
ukraine's children and families
in closing i'd like to express my
appreciation for the tremendous efforts
by our un teams both inside and outside
ukraine
and for the extraordinary solidarity
poland and other refugee hosting
countries continue to show
i would also like to express our
gratitude to our donors in every sector
your generosity has helped us bring hope
and help to children living through this
nightmare we're counting on you to help
us continue to help ukraine's children
and ukraine's children are counting on
all of us thank you all very much
thank you very much and now to conclude
that part
of of the session i would like to give
the floor to the director general of the
world health organization please you
have the floor
thank you thank you
moderator
i'm glad to be here in person in warsaw
and i would like to start by thanking
excellency prime minister murabishki and
excellency prime minister andorshin
it's often said that the first casualty
of war is truth
the same saying could apply equally to
health
the disruption of health services across
ukraine has been catastrophic
compounded by displacement and the fact
that millions of people remain trapped
in conflict areas
unable to move
this puts health workers care workers
services and infrastructure
and the health of millions of ukrainians
at severe risk
we salute the nurses caring for newborns
in hospital basements
ambulance drivers and paramedics
rescuing people from bombed buildings
medical teams conducting surgery and
delivering babies under fire you have
seen it all
but even worse than disruptions to
health services are attacks on health
care
who has now verified 191
attacks on health care
with 75 deaths and 54 injuries
hospitals clinics ambulances health
workers patients
let's be clear
attacks on health are a violation of
international humanitarian law
this is utterly unacceptable
who has more than 80 staff in ukraine
supported by hundreds more in
neighboring countries and around the
world
prior to the conflict who was working
with the ministry of health to prepare
for the worst case scenario
pre-positioning supplies in hospitals
within days of the russian federation's
invasion
we sent in medical supplies trauma kits
and more from our logistics hub in dubai
mobilizing also millions of dollars
so far we have delivered more than 316
metric tons of medical supplies
supporting care for 7.5 million people
and more than 200 000 surgeries
we're also working in neighboring
countries to support the health needs
of the more than five million refugees
who have now fled ukraine
who supports proposals
can i ask you to conclude please
surely yes just a few few sec solidarity
we doubled support proposals to provide
solidarity trust fund
and we thank donors who have supported
the health response so far and we hope
donors will make this appeal today a
success
we call for human human rights and
international humanitarian law to be
upheld to allow for safe and sustained
humanitarian assistance
we call for an immediate humanitarian
ceasefire for maury people and other
encircled cities to allow civilians to
evacuate
and to allow who and our partners to
deliver vital supplies and access health
needs
we call on the russian federation to
stop this war there is only one remedy
for the disease of war
peace
ukraine
peace for ukraine and i thank you
thank you very much and now we are
closing that part and we are moving to
uh the pledging sessions i think what
we've heard very clearly from the people
affected first and also from your own
remarks we understand why sustained
funding of the human response is so
needed so we will now hear some uh
pledges from
the delegation and we'll start with the
delegation that are with us in perfect
person and i would like to give the
floor to the prime minister of albania
to start please your excellency
thank you very much
i have i'll say very few words
starting from
[Music]
albania as a non-permanent
member of the united
nations security council
where we are
co-op and holders with the united states
for ukraine
and in coordination with other
like-minded countries
we are giving
our own contribution
in the initiation of
meetings and
drafting the documents regarding
war
and in full support of
ukraine
on the other hand bilaterally
we have been among the first to make our
contribution for ammunition
for the armed forces of ukraine
and
in the same time
we have
adopted
all the legal framework to allow
every ukrainian
people to come to our country
for a period of time they need or they
wish
so in this uh
donors conference albania aims to
contribute with 1 million euro
i know that this will not change the
destiny of the war or of the
reconstruction
but
we are very
honored to be here
and i am very thankful to both the prime
ministers of poland and sweden to
make us part of it
and uh
till the end we'll do our best
to honor our our obligation towards the
ukrainian
friends and the ukrainian people
aiming of course
what everybody aims here to
have a
end of this war and
to see peace
come as soon as possible
thank you very much
thank you very much your excellencies
and i would like to give the floor to
the prime minister of croatia please
thank you very much dear uh prime
minister morovian prime minister
anderson thank you very much for
inviting us here today it's a great
pleasure to be again
in warsaw and i would like to thank
president zelinski for his words and
also especially denis mikhail my friend
ukrainian prime minister for presenting
to us the entire concept of the
reconstruction of ukraine
we have all come as friends to warsaw we
have come as
prime ministers ministers and officials
who want to extend solidarity with
ukraine in the moment where russia's
aggression has not only hit
ukrainian women ukrainian children
ukrainian elderly civilians or soldiers
ukrainian houses ukrainian
infrastructure but it has hit on
ukrainian identity and on ukrainian
freedom
and this is key to understand what
russian aggressions has caused it has
caused pain
for
almost 13 million of those who in such a
short time had to leave their homes
for those who left ukraine almost six
millions and for the devastating
destruction that will that it will take
years to recover
croatia uh knows what being a victim of
aggression is and that's why we are here
with you and we shall stand by with you
as long as it takes today we shall
allocate another 5 million euros to
support this donor's confidence but it's
just a part of the contribution of our
consistent political diplomatic
humanitarian technical military aid that
we shall extend to you
croatia stands besides ukraine and we
shall be standing as long as it takes
thank you
thank you very much your excellencies i
would like now to give the floor to the
prime minister of finland please
thank you so much and first let me thank
poland and sweden dear mcdellen dear
matthews for hosting this event today
the humanitarian situation in ukraine is
extremely difficult
to due to russia's ongoing aggression it
is now crucial to achieve robust
ceasefire for the evocation of civilians
and the delivery of aid
we need to help those in the most
vulnerable positions women girl and
persons with disabilities
as the number of displaced people grows
we are all doing our utmost to protect
vulnerable groups from abuse and
trafficking finland is working with the
ukrainian authorities to transfer a
group of disabled persons and uncombined
minors to finland
finland has provided ukraine with
humanitarian and development age as well
as material and military assistance we
have made a national budget decision on
a further allocation of 700 million
euros to help ukrainian refugees in
finland
in addition to this we are currently
preparing an additional contribution to
cover current needs and to assess with
reconstruction the contribution subject
to parliamentary approval will be
approximately 70 million euros we have
also made a decision today to send
additional military equipment to ukraine
we strongly condemn russia's war of
aggression against ukraine finland is
ready to strengthen sanctions against
russia including in the energy sector
and i welcome the commission's newest
proposal on sanctions
russia must be held accountable for its
grave violations of human rights and
international humanitarian law finland
supports the investigation by the
international criminal court we have
granted financial support to the icc and
are seconding experts
in helping ukraine and ukrainians
solitary solidarity is the key ukraine
is fighting for europe and you are the
winners of this war
our thoughts are with you and our
actions are for the future of ukraine
and its brave people finland is ready to
do its part thank you
thank you very much your excellencies i
would like now to give the thought to
the prime minister of georgia
thank you very much dear colleagues dear
friends
honorable guests first of all i want to
thank prime minister maurowski and prime
minister anderson for co-hosting our
meeting today
as one of these team presidents of
european council and the european
commission
you've always been devoted partners of
georgia on our european and your
atlantic integration path
first of all i want to
mention that of course we condemn
russia's
full-scale military aggression against
ukraine
which is a clear
and blatant violation of fundamental
principles and norms of the
international law as well as the u.n
charter
the outcome of the war in ukraine will
define the future architecture of
european security
and laid the ground for the new secured
framework for our region and beyond
the award in ukraine has caused a major
humanitarian crisis in the region and
requires immediate action from the
international community
my government has stood in full
solidarity with the ukraine people
and mobilized our resources to elevate
the effects of the devastating war
we still fastly stand with the
international community in full
solidarity with ukraine
and we will continue supporting
ukraine politically and in practical
sense
both bilaterally and within multilateral
formats
the contribution that has already been
dispersed by georgia is valued at seven
million us dollars and we continue
providing assistance to more than 28 000
ukrainians affected by war and currently
living in georgia
more than 500 tons of humanitarian cargo
has been sent to ukraine by air and by
land
and my government has been supported to
the displaced people from ukraine
through provision of accommodation
essential items clothing food vital
medical services
access to schools and kindergartens free
of charge
and we continue supporting our brotherly
nation with additional
7 million us dollars by the end of 2022.
so in addition our private sector also
want to mention that ngos and individual
citizens are also offering accommodation
food clothing and other assistance to
the ukrainian citizens who live in
georgia
according to ukraine's national post
georgia is the first among 191 countries
in supply and humanitarian aid to
ukraine
therefore once again i want to mention
that the unity of the international
community
in providing active support to ukraine
is a matter of urgency and necessity i
wish again ukrainian ukraine people
peace and prosperity thank you very much
thank you very much your excellencies
and i would like now to end over the
the floor to the prime minister of
iceland please go ahead
thank you dear colleagues and dear
friends
iceland stands in full solidarity with
ukraine
in the face of russia's ongoing brutal
illegal military aggression and the
icelandic people stand with the
ukrainian people the people who thought
on the 24th of february that they were
going on with their daily lives going to
work meet their friends and family
people who want to live in a world where
we respect humanity human rights
where we value democracy and freedom
and where we solve our disputes with
dialogue and not war
as we have heard today there is no end
to the horrors of war death and
destruction and we are facing a
humanitarian crisis with more than 16
million people in the urgent need of
humanitarian aid
and allow me to pay my respects to the
people of the neighboring countries of
ukraine not least to our polish hosts
for their unwavering commitment to
assist the ukrainian neighbors
iceland is resolutely a part of a broad
international alliance to assist ukraine
and so far my government has contributed
roughly half a billion icelandic cronus
to humanitarian efforts which is
equivalent to 4.2 million euros
we have opened our doors to refugees as
of last week around 1 000 ukrainians
fleeing the war have been warmly
welcomed in iceland
we have placed a special focus on
assisting individuals and families of
vulnerable refugee groups including
disabled children and sick and endured
and their close relatives including
those hosted in moldova
and we need to pay special attention to
the fact that the war is impacting women
and men differently
not to mention the huge rise in
conflict-related sexual violence and
human trafficking
today i'm announcing the pledge of
additional 425 million icelandic kronos
the equivalent of 3 million euros
thereby almost doubling the total amount
from iceland allocated to humanitarian
and economic aid for ukraine and with
this pledge iceland's current
contribution stands at the equivalent of
7.2 million euros
humanitarian aid will be channeled
through different international
organizations and economic support
through the world's bank's multi-donor
trust funds for ukraine
dear friends i want to thank the
organizers prime minister moravetsi and
magdalena anderson for this initiative
our hosts here and all of you who
organized this
our solidarity which you have shown
through this war is our biggest strength
and our humanity is what unites us and
both is at this play here today thank
you
thank you very much your excellencies
and i would like now to give the floor
to the prime minister of sovlet slovakia
please go ahead
thank you very much first of all dear
magdalena thank you very much for
organizing this uh
very important event and it's cool
great to have dennis uh shmeehaw with us
wonderful
well what i first want to say that we
have to still have very strongly in mind
that this is not just a crisis this is a
war
brutal war
people are being killed innocent people
are being killed and that's why it's so
important that we meet on this kind of
event and we call to the whole world
that we won't stop helping ukraine
because
you are brave you showed such a bravery
in this time really you showed the
bravery to the whole world and and full
respect to that that you keeping in this
bravery till this day and you want to
win
this war and you will have our support
because we are your neighbor but we are
not just a neighbor we are also a friend
and we understand just like andre said
in in uh from croatia we fully
understand what you're fighting for
you're fighting for our values you're
fighting for the freedom you have to pay
with blood
and will support you that you don't have
to pay anymore and that's why i'm so
glad that the democratic world
understands how important is to provide
you all the help you said you named it
your weapons ammunition sanctions
everything that you said humanitarian
and we as a neighbor of course all the
ukrainians who needed to to find the
refuge before the
the war they find found a refuge in
slovakia and they will as long as they
need to uh
till they come back
and i know they want to come back
because we speak to them and it's such a
wonderful thing from your people that
they they honor the leadership they
honor your country and they want to go
back so we'll definitely support you
because i think the important thing is
we're writing a history we need to show
to every dictator from this moment for
the future that war is not the solution
that he will be isolated immediately
this is what we need to that's why our
response is so important
that's why we need to be so united and
so strong and keep going until we stop
uh vladimir putin and and you will have
your your victory we want you to be a
stable and prosperous uh country freedom
democracy that's what you deserve and
therefore we are a strong advocate for
your candidate status and i think you
can do it just like voladimerzelansky
said that i believe that you can do in
an expedited debate because we as a
slovakia went through same experience
european commission provided us a strong
help and we advocate for a reform team
for you because i think you can do it in
really very quick time and and that's
what we will be advocating for you and
uh that's uh that's our support uh for
you as well and the last thing of course
any help you need we participated on the
pledge a month ago where we pledged over
500 million euros for for the help
needed we approving whenever you need
something from the military aid we are
proving it immediately will help you to
repair your equipment and if there will
be any request from the weapons that we
have we'll gladly provide because i
think that's the right attitude in this
situation you need to win this war we
are there here with this in you
or in this with you and uh we all united
you are europe you are one of us
thank you
thank you very much your excellencies i
would like to give the floor to the
prime minister of slovenia please
thank you dear magdalena der mateos
dear colleagues excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
i would also like to join all of you and
stress once again the importance and the
timely
organization of this pledging conference
as the russian illegal and unprovoked
aggression against ukraine protracts in
time
we are witnessing one of the worst
humanitarian disasters
at the same time we are filled with
admiration for for the ukrainians who
are showing immense courage
defending their homeland
and at the same time fighting for the
universal values of freedom and
democracy
president zelensky prime minister
mikhail ukrainian government and
ukrainian people
are a true inspiration for us all
when we visited you in the middle of
march together with mateos and peter
we saw that ukraine will never be
defeated
and
the
main question when this war will come to
an end
mostly
apply
in your courage and in our help
this is combination which will prevail
and also proud that the european union
has showed a high level of unity in
responding to the russian aggression as
well
as well
as effectiveness in providing assistance
we have stood up in this war we will
overcome it and we will prepare
and we are we look forward to the day in
the near future when we can welcome
ukraine as a full member of the european
union
slovenia
commands especially poland and all other
neighboring countries of ukraine
for their generous hospitality and
welcoming millions of ukraine refugees
more than 60 000 ukrainian refugees
came to slovenia too
and a big part of its found shelter in
slovenia just a few days ago
a group of orphans were relocated to our
country to escape from the dangers of
war
we responded in line with our moral
obligation site of material technical
and military donations
we
we have donated several million billions
euros
to different humanitarian locations for
ukraine and we are increasing today for
another million
through the unicef found and
traditionally in kind assistance for
ukrainian people we are also
preparing a special law for on ukraine
to pass
through slovenian parliament to shorten
the shorten the procedures to be able to
deliver help on time
so we stand in solidarity with ukraine
slavo ukraine
thank you very much prime minister and i
would like to uh to move and give the
thought to the prime minister for
romania
with join us
via video conference
please go ahead
okay
uh
good afternoon excellencies
distinguished participants ladies and
gentlemen first of all let me thank to
prime minister anderson and prime
minister
moravietsky for hosting
uh today's event
i would like also to salute the presence
of prime minister mihal
and also to express our outmost
appreciations for
ukrainian
uh people's
brave resistance
ukraine and his people
of course need our support in the
immediate but also for reconstruction
i have witnessed myself
during my recent visit to kiev
erpin and
borodianca the large scale of human
suffering
and the destruction inflicted so far by
the russian illegal
unprovoked and
unjustified military aggression
i'd like to reassure from the outset
of the solid and continued support of
the romanian government
citizens and civil society for ukraine
from the beginning of the world to the
date
romanian's assistance has been
multi-dimensional
the romanian government
has made several humanitarian donation
which totaled over 6 million euros
in addition to this we pledged an
additional in-kind offer of 3.2 million
euro
representing 1 900 tons of fuel
moreover
the humanitarian hub in the north of
romania dispatches humanitarian aid
for the idps in ukraine and those
affected
by the disruption of war
the romanian government also implements
a comprehensive set of measures
in support of
ukrainian
refugees
these measures involve funds of over
70 million euro
in support of the
economy of ukraine
romania took the initiative of
liberalizing transport conditions for
ukrainian exports
especially for agriculture products
these measures allows ukraine to
continue exporting
is ex sorry essential agriculture output
thus mitigating the volatility and
disruption of international markets
while
generating much needed income for our
ukrainian neighbors
romania will continue to stand by
ukraine
including in the reconstruction process
in our view
the rebuilding and reconstruction
process
should be considered and designed from a
broader perspective
by investing both in rebuilding the
economy and the infrastructure
while consolidating the democratic
institutions
the reconstruction process and efforts
of advancing democratic values and
practices
will accompany ukrainians european
perspective
in this regard romania's position is
consistent and clear-cut
prime minister prime minister
prime minister can i ask you to conclude
please thank you
yes
so strong support for the european
perspective of ukraine and
in a similar logic for republic of
moldova in georgia thank you very much
for your attention slava ukraine
thank you very much prime minister and i
would like now to give the floor to the
prime minister of serbia that is joining
us also via video conference please you
have the floor go ahead
thank you very much esteemed prime
minister morovian esteemed prime
minister
anderson distinguished president of the
european council and president of the
european commission
dear colleagues
i would like to thank you for organizing
this high-level international donors
conference
giving us the opportunity to express
solidarity with the people of ukraine
since the outbreak of the conflict the
republic of serbia has been observing
with particular concern its adverse
consequences for the civilian population
rapid deterioration of the humanitarian
situation and the growing number of
refugees and internally displaced
persons
serbia condemns all attacks on civilian
population and civilian objects
and any use of force contrary to
international humanitarian law
we call for creating conditions for the
delivery of humanitarian aid and support
all efforts to end the conflict
serbia voted for the resolution on the
humanitarian consequences of the
aggression against ukraine adopted by
the united nations general assembly on
the 24th of march
on the 27th of february
the government of serbia adopted the
decision
to provide any kind of humanitarian aid
to endangered ukrainian people
and activated the temporary protection
mechanism for displaced persons coming
from ukraine
this is the first time that such legal
mechanism is employed in our country
serbia supports the activities
undertaken by the united nations and the
international humanitarian actors to
urgently address the needs of the most
vulnerable categories affected by the
conflict and for that reason i take this
opportunity to pledge 3 million euros
from serbia for the humanitarian
response in ukraine
this package of support will be
allocated via united nations agencies
working on the ground namely unicef and
unhcr
the people of serbia sympathize with the
people of ukraine in their desire to
return to normal life in which future
generations will live without the fear
of war
thank you
thank you very much prime minister uh
thank you for uh for this word and allow
me also to just acknowledge we've
received a lot of statement and pledge
pre-recorded by many states i just want
to to name the netherlands new zealand
denmark israel estonia canada united
kingdom luxembourg liechtenstein malta
colombia norway germany france portugal
and the u.s and we would have the chance
to see them maybe later on uh when
possible uh i would like now to uh to
call uh um your excellency minister
uh
rabb from austria please
thank you prime minister moravietsky
prime minister anderson
president michelle president fonderland
prime minister smeal and dear colleagues
i would like to first thank the
governments of poland and sweden as well
as the presidents of the european
council and the european commission for
convening today's conference
the 24th of february 2022 was a turning
point
in the modern european history
the unprovoked and unjustified russian
attack on ukraine is a blatant breach of
international law and it undermines
european security and stability
it has caused unimaginable destruction
and suffering of the civilian population
we would have hoped to
never see in europe again
this brutal war is sending shockwaves
around the world we are all horrified by
the pictures
and reports that continue to reach us
from ukraine and
the number of people in need of
humanitarian assistance is staggering
austria stands with ukraine we will of
course continue to give temporary
protection to those who escape the war
in ukraine so far it's been more than
60
7 000 ukrainians who registered in
austria and we will continue to provide
support on the ground
as
it is reported that more than 15 million
people in ukraine are in desperate need
of humanitarian aid
austria has indeed a long-standing
tradition of engaging in humanitarian
aid in ukraine and
of providing assistance to the civilian
population of countries affected by
humanitarian crises
since the beginning of the aggression
against ukraine austria has contributed
19.6 million euros via its international
humanitarian partners
and we also offered in-kind assistance
via the eu's crisis protection mechanism
to ukraine and its neighboring states
affected by the refugee crisis
in line with that tradition
i'm glad to announce that austria will
provide a further
41.96 million euros or
44.2 million us dollars
from its foreign disaster relief fund
via austrian ngos to alleviate
the humanitarian crisis in ukraine and
its neighboring countries
15 million of these funds will go
directly into
the support of women and children for
one thing it's sad reality it is
particularly women and children who
suffer in the senseless war
and who require particular humanitarian
assistance as well as protection from
violence and human trafficking
the austrian government's commitment of
141.96 million
euros matches the exact same amount of
donations people in austria have already
made in a display of incredible
solidarity with ukraine
in order to provide people in need with
basic livelihoods and services it is
imperative that unitarian organizations
have free and unhindered access to
people in need and that their safety and
security is guaranteed let me thank
our humanitarian partners for their
outstanding efforts under these very
difficult circumstances
thank you very much for your attention
thank you minister and i would like now
to give the floor to his excellency mr
foreign affair for the czech republic
please
we have the floor thank you very much
dear prime minister smihal dear prime
minister's excellencies ladies and
gentlemen
i would like to commend the government
of poland and sweden for convening this
conference
together with most of
the countries of the world shakia has
strongly condemned the armed violence
and widespread indiscriminate attacks on
civilian population and infrastructure
in ukraine
we also condemned the continued violence
of international humanitarian law by
russia
it is important publicly to reaffirm our
commitment towards the affected
population of ukraine
including internally displaced people
and refugees from ukraine in our region
we have to scale up our humanitarian
assistance as well as our advocacy
since the beginning of the russian war
in ukraine shakia has provided
humanitarian assistance worth
22 million euro to the affected
population in ukraine as well as to
refugees from ukraine in particular in
moldova
in view of the continued war and growing
needs i would like to confirm a
mobilization of additional 18 million
euro for the ongoing humanitarian
assistance by the czech government
apart from public and in private in kind
and financial donation exceeding 80
million euro already
czechia is also one of the countries of
destination for refugees from ukraine
more than 300 000 refugees have been
granted the temporary protection most of
them being women with children
uh it consists three percent of our
population we are 10 million country
the war in ukraine and its humanitarian
and geopolitical consequences has also
set up upcoming eu presidencies
priorities under review
and during the czech presidency we are
ready to initiate a comprehensive
stabilization reconstructions and
resilience program for and with ukraine
with the regional dimension targeting
resilience of moldova and georgia as
well
not least in the areas of energy and
cyber security
if the situation allow it in line with
the march european council consolation
conclusions we would like as the
presidency like to facilitate
organization of international donor
conference in support of the
reconstruction program
which would raise financial
contributions foster long-term
investment initiatives and identify
expertise both from public private and
civil society sectors
allow me to express my hope that the war
in ukraine i will be soon
will soon event
uh while our solidarity and cooperation
with ukraine and its population will be
further enhanced
thank you very much
thank you very much your excellencies
and i would like to give the thought to
the mist of foreign affair from hungary
please
thank you very much dear prime ministers
and dear colleagues i'm representing a
hungary which is a direct neighbor to
ukraine so the war in ukraine definitely
puts a security risk on ourselves as a
neighboring country as well
we hungarians did not and do not want
this war to the contrary we want peace
to return to our region as soon as
possible
and although we made it very clear i
want to underline it here as well repeat
it in order to
enable everybody to hear and understand
hungary stands for ukraine and the
sovereignty of the country
we can make a clear differentiation
between those who attack
and those who are attacked and we do
condemn the military aggression of the
russian federation against ukraine
and we do condemn the serious violation
of human rights and we do urge for
immediate investigation of all possible
war crimes uh committed
and our solidarity has already been
proven by the fact that we have received
670 670 thousand
refugees arriving from ukraine we
provide all of them with shelter
accommodation and food and we offer job
for all those who intend to stay on a
longer term and we definitely ensure
schooling for the kids of those who stay
for a longer time and i'd like to
underline that we will allow all the
refugees from ukraine to enter the
territory of hungary and we will help
all of them
let me now
share with you our set of pledges which
contains five elements first
we are ready to take part in the
reconstruction of a school and the
hospital in its entirety in the kiev
region
of course if the ukrainian authorities
demand
for another location we are ready to
adjust ourselves no question
second we understand the growing number
of internally displaced persons who
escape from the war and
and arrive to the western part of
ukraine to survive basically we are
ready to provide them with mobile homes
we are ready to start the deliveries uh
basically anytime you
require that and i would like to mention
here the the fantastic job the
tremendous job which is performed by
governor mikita in transcarpatia who
makes his best to ensure peace and
stability in that region third we are
ready to provide 1 000 fully state
finance scholarships for students who
had to flee from ukraine on the
hungarian universities to enable them to
continue or to complete their studies
fourth we are ready to provide a
treatment and medical service to wounded
ukrainian troops on the india hungarian
hospitals without any any kind of
limitation on numbers
and fifth we are ready to provide
hospitalization for a hundred and thirty
children from ukraine in our specialized
hospitals all together this set of
pledges of five elements have a total
amount of 37 million euros and we hope
dear colleagues mr prime minister that
this war comes to
its end soon we are praying for that as
well and we do hope that peace returns
to our region thank you
thank you for your excellent season i
would like now to give the floor to the
minister of foreign affairs from latvia
please please go ahead
thank you very much and first of all
thank you for poland and sweden for
convening this conference
i think that the principle of this
conference should be the longer the
speech the greater the pledge so i'll be
as brief as possible
but um let me say that latvia has been a
very committed supporter of ukraine we
have already provided medical i.t
support transportation support
military aid has exceeded 200 million
euros
and definitely we
intend to continue
we are planning also to participate in
the reconstruction of infrastructure of
schools of kindergartens
hospitals through our bilateral
development assistance
but we has already provided 5 million
euros through world bank to help cover
budgetary needs and today
announce our pledge
and the plan to double
our contribution by
10 million euros for ibrd's ukraine
emergency public service support program
we'll continue working with our
ukrainian friends to address
the needs
as they arise
and we also believe that actually the
best help
to ukraine would be granting the
candidate status
to ukraine in the next
eu summit and also
working to end this war as quickly as
possible through the victory of
ukraine thank you
thank you your excellencies and i would
like now to give the floor to the
ambassador for australia to ukraine
please
you have the floor
thank you
president's prime minister's
excellencies australia stands with
ukraine in its fight for survival and
condemns russia's unprovoked unjust and
illegal invasion in the strongest
possible terms
australia is horrified by the scale of
this humanitarian disaster and the
damage being caused by russia's war in
ukraine
over recent weeks when speaking with
colleagues who have returned to kiev
and passed through the formerly peaceful
towns of butcher urpin
byronka
they have conveyed to me the
unfathomable extent of devastation
particularly in civilian areas and
against civilian infrastructure
this is a brutal war
not just against an army but against a
people
we abhor continuing accounts of russia's
indiscriminate attacks on civilians
and are extremely concerned by reports
that more than 12 million ukrainians are
now displaced
internally and across borders and that
over one million ukrainians have been
forcibly deported to russia
many have faced terrible abuse and that
is why we have pledged so far
65 million australian dollars
towards meeting the urgent humanitarian
needs of the ukrainian people in ukraine
and in neighbouring countries
this is in addition to over 225 million
dollars in military assistance to
ukraine and an extensive
autonomous sanctions regime
and we will continue to do more
all australian government funding
provided to date
has been delivered through trusted
humanitarian partners including the un
and non-governmental organizations
our partners are now in turn delivering
on the ground for the people of ukraine
we are also working in partnership with
the united kingdom to get urgent relief
supplies directly into ukraine where
they're so keenly needed
donations from the generous australian
public including through
may i ask you to conclude yes indeed
donations from ukrainian diaspora are
supplementing these contributions and
it's clear from these donations and
contributions australians recognize the
injustice being perpetrated by russia
ukraine needs sustained practical
support from us all australia welcomes
the contributions and assistance of
other nations who are working to support
ukraine and we're pleased to be a key
partner in this effort
thank you ambassador and now let me give
you the floor to uh his excellency or
excellency the minister of foreign
affairs from lithuania
please you have the floor
thank you very much
let me extend the appreciation to the
governments of poland and sweden for
hosting this very important and timely
event
personally me
talking about ukraine is really very
emotional because my granddaughter was
ukrainian and um still have relatives
there so everything was happens there
really
affects
lithuanian society as well because i
think that many european citizens have
their relatives in in ukraine as well as
i do
and that means then ukraine was always
the big part of
europeans history and definitely will be
the big part of europe's future and i
hope the part of european union's future
as well and since the beginning of
russia's war in ukraine the lithuania
lithuanian institutions provided
124 million euros assistance to ukraine
and weapons
humanitarian aid also financial help
and lithuania is a great supporter to
ukraine not only by this support but
also calling for further sanctions on on
russia and uh
by
weakening russia's possibilities to
continue with this war and
preventing the another wars in europe as
well and i think it's really important
is to to talk also about uh freeze
russian assets in the in this in this uh
appeal because uh when we we are talking
about reconstructing ukraine definitely
we will need a
huge amount of funds and this is a
possibility to say that the aggressor
must pay for his actions
and talking about the additional health
in lithuania now there is about two
percent of our total population there
refugees from ukraine from ukraine and
in in the revised budget of the state
370 million euros is dedicated to the
support of these refugees and also we're
continuing our support in the
international financial institutions
support for for ukraine
it was in the world bank's instrument
multi-donor trust fund 5 million euros
in grants
also two weeks ago in the supreme
meetings i announced about 10 million
euros in grants and today i'm happy to
announce that we uh
helping ukraine in support of the for
the support for internally displaced
persons uh we
will donate to ukraine two million euros
thank you
thank you very much your excellencies
and i would like now to give the thought
to the ambassador for japan
to ukraine
please thank you very much and first of
all prime minister shimhari i'm very
pleased to see you again
and let me extend that
respect and gratitude to prime minister
of poland and sweden
for including japan in this very
important and timely conference now what
we've been witnessing is certainly the
largest humanitarian crisis and trustee
of course for ukraine first and also
europe
but
we started to feel that you know now
impact
of the russian aggressions
started to go beyond ukraine europe and
region to east asia where japan is
located and other parts of the world
so this is
the reason why we fully understand
believe that japan should be represented
in this conference so thank you very
much for extending your invitations now
what we have done and what we are going
to do is first emergency humanitarian
aid and we have already pledged and
started to supply
200 million u.s dollars
now second
when it comes to the direct budgetary
and economic support financial support
to ukraine
we have pledged and we are soon going to
provide
300 million u.s dollars to ukrainian
government
and third
tokyo is encouraging all the japanese
local governments and municipalities in
joining us in the constructions and
recovery operations when it is possible
and last but not least prime minister of
japan foreign minister of japan
personally
reaching out to the other governments in
asia
to join us in a
support of the ukraine particularly in
the form of the financial support and
also joining us in sanctions against
russia so prime minister mihali i can
assure you that next time i definitely
come to see you in kiev thank you very
much
thank you very much ambassador i just
would like to give you a bit of a
perspective about will happen in the
coming minutes so i would like to ask
two more statements and then i know i'm
looking already at our two prime
minister hosting to give you concluding
remark i know that the press and the
press conference is an important one
that you will have to depart
and then i would ask the other speakers
to stay to continue because i think we
want to be able to listen to your
statement just to give you a sense of
what is coming to happen in the next 30
minutes so please let me give this the
floor now to the deputy director
of the swiss agency for development and
cooperation please you have the floor
thank you very much chair
co-hosts
prime minister excellencies switzerland
is here with pleasure switzerland here
is his honor and switzerland this year
was full of commitments we have three
roles that we want to fulfill one as a
donor our government increased its
humanitarian funding to 80 million this
design and parallel to our development
corporation we want to continue to be an
actor we opened a couple of weeks ago
our basis in life where we work with the
local council with local organizations
in order to repair infrastructure to
support host families to support the
displaced person and switzerland wants
to be here as an advocate we face the
grim
fact that millions of people cannot be
reached this is a blunt uh violation of
international humanitarian law
switzerland as the depository state of
geneva appeals to all
um state parties to all
warring parties to respect humanitarian
law now we have
also to think to the next step
and to link these relief operations with
recovery
with rehabilitation we are very
committed to quality humanitarian aid
but we want to reach out to reach out to
the next step and in this regard we look
forward to country-led multi-stakeholder
operations together with the authorities
on the ground thank you very much back
to you chair
thank you very much ambassador and
director general i would like now to
give the floor to the minister kitty
from belgium joining us uh by ovia video
conferences
please the floor is yours thank you very
much
thank you very much thank you very much
dear colleagues
um more than two months after the
russian invasion
new human suffering continues to grow in
ukraine wherever the war is
pace the highest price
24 million of them need our support
we can't look away when fathers need to
stay
to say goodbye to their children
and mothers fear bombs at the places
they could once call home
belgium strongly condemned the attacks
against civil civilians and civilian
infrastructure
international humanitarian law must be
respected we must show all people in
ukraine that we stand by them in
solidarity and i am particularly worried
about the children and the women in
ukraine or those who fled the country we
have to do everything to make sure that
they are protected and i want to thank
our partners un organizations and the
icrc for all the work they are doing
they evacuate the evacuation of more
than 100 people from
mario poll this week shows again that
their work is truly life-saving
in view of growing needs i'm happy to
announce that belgium will step up for
the urgent humanitarian and social needs
we will scale up our support to a total
of 30 million euros for the people of
ukraine as part of a larger efforts of
the belgian government
this funding will be directed to the
most urgent humanitarian needs as well
as the support for social basic services
it comes on top of our flexible funding
to humanitarian organizations and aid
convoys sent to
ukraine and the neighborhooding
countries
i would like each of us to remember that
there is a person behind us huge numbers
of people in need so let's not forget
them let's not fail them let's not fail
the people of ukraine thank you very
much
thank you very much your excellencies
and i see that we still have a bit of
time to have few more statements i'm
watching very carefully the two prime
minister you let me know so i would like
to give the floor to the president van
oyer of the european u investment bank
please uh president
excellencies let me thank you very much
for inviting the eu bank to this
important conference
eib is here for a free
independent ukraine
we have been in ukraine for quite a
while in particular increase after 2014
when after the aggression on crimea we
stopped our business in russia and
redirected funds
we are proud that we managed to rapidly
deploy almost 700 million euros to the
ukrainian government for urgent
liquidity needs just a few days after
the
russian
aggression
in addition we are now
providing 4 billion euros for ukrainians
who had to flee their country that means
in the member state of the european
union but also in other neighboring
countries
but our main role does not lie in grant
funding or budget support it lies in
concrete investments in support of eu
policies in our member states and
partner countries the ib is there
because in addition to humanitarian
assistance there is an urgent need
to rebuild critical infrastructure to
help ukraine and its people to remain
resilient while they defend themselves
in our european values against russia's
aggression this is where eib working in
partnership with other ifis including
our friends at ebrd
and of course with the european
commission can provide technical
experience and financial expertise
subject to the availability of the eu
guarantee
we can immediately accelerate the
delivery of up to 1.5 billion euros to
address some of the most urgent needs
these are rather visible and symbolic
projects like rebuilding of schools
bridges hospitals and so forth
i think the eib is there because the
planning phase for countrywide
reconstruction should start now even the
full-scale rebuilding can only take
place once the war is over the challenge
will be immense and we should be ready
we stand ready to help ukraine to
develop a comprehensive strategy for
financing the reconstruction we are also
well placed to take an
important role in the financial
management of a solidarity fund under
the policies dear of the european
commission if asked to do so we have
rebuilt before
and together with all of you in
solidarity with ukraine we will build
again
rebuild back back again creating the
conditions for a better future thank you
very much
thank you very much president now to
give the floor to a representative of
business and that's very important to
have you here around the table thank you
for that so i would like to to call
first representative of google uh mr
matthew john britton please you have the
floor
thank you and thank you to our political
leaders for bringing us together for
this important uh moment i'm at britain
i run google in europe the middle east
and africa and uh from google a thousand
of us in poland tens of thousands across
europe and all around the world we stand
with you the people of ukraine uh we'll
continue to play our part and i think
the last two years have shown us when
governments companies and communities
come together we can confront crises at
our best from our side we have uh across
the world donated 35 million to in-kind
and humanitarian support to aid relief
efforts for the people in ukraine
already as well as for those fleeing the
war that includes 10 million to poland
organizations working with temporarily
displaced people a city which has become
such a symbol of safety and solidarity
in this crisis and yesterday we
announced a 1.5 million grant
to our colleagues international rescue
committee to expand critical information
support to united for ukraine which is
an information portal for civil society
effort to help people find information
on housing
legal aid and psychological support and
today we pledge a further 10 million
dollars in cash grants and in-kind
humanitarian support for people in
ukraine bringing our total commitment
from google and from our employees
directly to 45 million dollars and from
the start of the war we've also focused
on information and cyber security we
know that people turn to us for
information and accurate and timely
information in a time of war can be the
difference between
life and death so we work round the
clock since all this began to make our
tools and technology as helpful as
possible to those in need rapid air
alerts to people with android mobile
phones in ukraine or shelter and
humanitarian aid points uh for those
fleeing and also protecting you i need
you
please
um so we're shielding 180 ukrainian
sites government and other information
sites against those things and our ceo
when visiting warsaw recently also
pledged a further 10 million to
fight misinformation in the region so
we played an additional 10 million today
bringing us to 45 million dollars in
total with a further 10 million for
fighting misinformation we stand here to
work with all of you political leaders
ngos and communities and the people of
ukraine
thank you very much and i would like you
to give the floor to the representative
for astrazeneca mr hans si bisma please
thank you thank you very much
um on behalf of my company astrazeneca i
would like to thank the prime ministers
of poland and prime minister of um
sweden for hosting this event and for
inviting us to this important conference
it's an honor for us to be here
in this unitarian crisis
we are deeply impressed by the efforts
of the polish government
as well as the polish community
to support the people of ukraine
we have ourselves as our company 200
ukrainian employees
many of whom
are now being hosted here in poland and
are benefiting benefiting from this
support
astrazeneca
is very committed to response efforts
we're having we have given already seven
million in humanitarian support
to date including donations to the red
cross as well as medicines donations
in line with our purpose as a healthcare
company we're also doing
everything possible to ensure that
patients can continue to access our
essential and life-saving medicines
our priorities go with our employees the
patients
refugees and of course all those who are
impacted by this tragic and devastating
war
our efforts do not stop here
on behalf of assassina i'm pleased and
proud to confirm
our response to the call to action and
to pledge to donate today an additional
3 million us dollars in humanitarian
support
raising our total contribution to over
10 million us dollars
we strongly believe
that it's our responsibility to continue
to contribute to humanitarian relief
efforts and to support the people of
ukraine
thank you very much it's an honor for us
to be here
thank you very much and the last
representative of of the business sector
boston consulting group the chairman of
the board mr mr hooten kapinsi please
you have the floor
thank you for inviting me to this
important conference
the boston consulting group
tries to help in the best way we can
through pro bono projects or donations
we do five things firstly we develop the
app
to find a shelter
where there is 10 000 already matches
it's a peer-to-peer app functioning very
successful and we are developing this
further in poland but also in other
markets second thing we do the analysis
of the pain points of the refugees and
one of the biggest is education so we
help with the summer camps to organize
summer camp three we
organize donations among our consultants
we collected 1.5 million euro
[Music]
through just donations
next one we organize forums for uh for
the ceo of largest firms globally to
drive awareness
and the last one we
built
virtual ukrainian
office where we re recruit
uh ukrainians across the globe
for the future when the office can be
restarted
thanks to everybody i'm also impressed
by everybody who is doing so much
thank you very much a new statement
conclude in fact this long but very
important sessions i would like now to
turn to our co-host to give their brief
in fact uh remarks and concluding
remarks and then i know that both of you
will have to leave including the prime
minister of ukraine will leave also for
the press conference i just would like
to flag already that at 2 45 i repeat 2
45 we are resuming here for the round
table and the round table will be in the
presence of the prime minister of
ukraine and a lot of different people
talking in fact about
long-term needs and how do we try to to
think and do a road map about some of
the questions so 245 please but first
our two co-hosts i give the floor to the
prime minister of sweden please
excellencies and friends thank you all
for attending this conference
and your participation is an important
signal of solidarity
with the people of ukraine and on behalf
of the swedish government i want to
convey my
sincere thanks to my colleague and
co-host matthias and acknowledge the
leadership of poland during this crisis
i would also like to recognize the
strong message from president zielinski
and prime minister sihal
illustrating both the
plight and courage of ukrainian people
and i also also like to thank charles
and ursula for being our partners in
conference
and of course also un and humanitarian
partners who are present today
through them we convey our appreciation
for all the humanitarian partners who
are working under dangerous
circumstances
working to meet the urgent and growing
needs of women men and children in
ukraine
and their needs continue to grow because
of the war so this conference is very
important from that aspect
i would also like to thank everyone who
has participated today
presidents prime ministers and ministers
for their generous contributions to help
the people of ukraine
your pledges will allow the united
nations the red cross movement and other
humanitarian organizations to deliver
aid to those most in need and i'm happy
to say that it looks like we have
surpassed our expectations today
going forward support for better ukraine
remains critical and immediate financing
needs are enormous so we look forward to
continuing our dialogue today with a
high level roundtable on measures to
support ukraine's effort to meet the
economic challenges created by the war
and rebuild ukraine
the war is human tragedy
russia must end its aggression now and
this is easy to do you can just go back
and go home
and today from warsaw we have
collectively sent a strong message that
we stand with ukraine in these dark
times and that we will continue to
support the people of ukraine
and it is my strong belief that
brighter days lie ahead so that children
like ilya of whom i spoke earlier can
return back home go to school and play
with his friends
in peace
thank you
thank you very much uh prime minister
your excellencies now would like to give
the thought to the prime minister of
poland please
thank you for
all the pledges made so far and for all
the efforts for
that you have been making before
at the same time i want to urge you to
work even closer with our government and
the government of ukraine we are in
permanent daily contact with dennis with
president zawinski
our logistics system is able allows for
much more efforts much more efficient
delivery of humanitarian aid
and we are able to reach out even the
most remote areas of the country which
dennis can can confirm because we are
doing this every day deliveries of
lorries tracks going from
our southeastern part of poland to all
the cities and towns
in ukraine
and let us not forget also about the
refugees who were forced to leave
ukraine
everyone seeking shelter in poland is
receiving housing food health care
free public transportation and free
schooling for children we refused to
create permanent refugee camps opting
for full integration of refugees with
our society at least at this juncture as
long as they want to be with with us and
of course we all hope for them to be
able to go back to ukraine as soon as
possible
this is a more costly approach but much
more sustainable and much more humane
with enormous help of millions of polish
families we are able to create a
welcoming and open environment allowing
all the refugees to find their second
home in our country
i can declare that poland will continue
the support for ukrainian refugees
with no less than equivalent of
additional uh 3.4 billion euro till the
end of this year
the money will be will be spent on
subsidizing accommodation family support
programs free public transports and
other means of support
on top of that we will continue to
provide free education healthcare and
other public services
language courses
access to our labor market and many
other
in addition now to our in addition to
our efforts at home i'm glad to announce
that poland will deliver additional 100
million euro of humanitarian aid to
ukraine food medicine hygiene products
housing units these are these container
type of
towns which we already have built uh
several of the those in ukraine
and other equipment
while this conference is focused on the
humanitarian aid
i don't want to omit
the level of military support that
poland has been providing worth over 1.6
billion euro only until today
this support will also continue and
increase in every necessary and possible
way
last but not least i want to underline
that we are all we all must increase
pressure on russia
sanctions have to be severe
poland will become fully independent
from russian gas and oil very soon
we we have been already cut off russian
gas as you probably might have heard one
week ago or two weeks ago
because we didn't want to agree on
paying in rebels
i call on all the european governments
to follow and i'm
glad to see many of our government's
proposals reflected in the six package
of sanctions
full embargo on russian gas and oil are
needed with secondary sanctions that
prevent from circumventing the ban
and we must ensure a full and permanent
confiscation of russian assets and
federal reserves
this cannot be a taboo any longer full
cost confiscation of russian
assets russian oligarchs and russian
federation and this has to be dedicated
for the recovery of ukraine
reconstruction of ukraine
later today we will be discussing the
reconstruction of ukraine it is russia
that started this war and russia has to
pay for this its consequences
this requires both political decisions
this requires courage and state
mentorship i strongly believe that we
are capable of doing this
the time is now
thank you for all the pledges i have
just received the final number and i'm
very glad
to announce that all of us managed to
mobilize
6.5 billion dollars these are pledges
which were put
and thank you
also in the in all the videos which are
available
let us make sure that these funds reach
ukrainian people as quickly as
efficiently and efficiently as possible
today has shown that our support for
ukraine continues and that here is no
selfishness among us
and it is very good conclusion because
if selfishness wins
putin wins if unity wins ukraine wins
and we all win
this is the message i would like to
leave
you with
once again thank you for all your time
and commitment and let us celebrate that
and celebrate all ukrainian heroes
in particular all ukrainian heroes with
a round of applause thank you very much
thank you very much thank you very much
uh and thank you also for hosting in
fact this conference and for your
generosity here prime minister uh i'll
leave you i'll let you go i know that
you have now the press conference i just
would like to remember the people that
we are reconvening at 2 45 to really
explore some of the questions related to
the economic needs
for ukraine over the long time 245 thank
you very much
[Music]
thank you
is
foreign
see
so
foreign
okay
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
somebody
okay
so
not
so
so
hey look
welcome to the international donors
conference for ukraine i would now like
to give the floor to the prime minister
of poland mr matas marawinski
you very much for all of you who
came to poland who came to warsaw and
all of you who
also pledged so much for to support
ukraine
i'm gonna personally thank first
magdalena anderson
prime minister of sweden
uh poland and sweden
we are always so much close working
towards
um
ukraine and eastern partnership
and this is also
today a very clear sign of
cooperation and thank you magdalena for
this and also usually
thank you for your presence towards so
uh the president of the european
commission is enormously involved in
supporting ukraine
on all uh different
occasions and many different aspects so
uh really thank you very very much
rasula for all what you are doing and
also i'm gonna thank charles michelle
who is not with us
right now but who
was with us
at the conference
and thank you dennis for coming to this
important
conference
i also like to take this opportunity to
thank all the polish citizens and
everybody who is involved in supporting
ukrainian refugees
and
who is involved in gathering
uh all the funds to support ukraine we
have to bear in mind that we are all
active and we try to actively
and effectively support ukraine but they
are fighting for all of us they are
fighting for the freedom of ukraine but
they are fighting for security and peace
in europe
and
this
connectivity this link cannot be
forgotten
like history teaches us also that for
civilians were almost always means fear
and death
and hunger
in ukraine we are
not dealing with an ordinary war
it is an assault justified by lies
and carried out by
criminals for human rights
are an abstraction and for whom cruelty
is a way to win cruelty is a way to
win for the russians
this means
the in describable uh misery of the
citizens of
uh invaded country and we encounter this
we see this every day we
see
ukrainian soldiers in our hospitals we
see ukrainian refugees and we see people
of ukraine in ukraine suffering
enormously
so this is why i believe
that the time for
acting time to act is
is now and we have to
remind ourselves about this every every
day
photos from today's ukraine
differ
from those from world war ii only in
resolution and color that
cities under siege and people
starved to death
it seemed like scenes from the 70 years
ago but this is this is today and we we
see this
every day
unimaginable losses
numbers of hospitals schools
kindergarten
housing estates we see this every day
but
we cannot
get used to this those pictures we
we have to
be
decisive enough and patient enough
to support ukraine in everything
what
ukrainian people are doing to defend
their their freedom their sovereignty
and their territorial
integrity
on this
conference we were able to gather more
than 6 billion euro and this money will
be
dispatch will be distributed distributed
to support ukraine and all those who
support ukraine because
we know how
painfully and how costly it is
for the ukrainian nation
when
russia
brings death the countries of the free
world
have to
bring
aid and and i think this conference here
in warsaw
showed enormous uh amount of solidarity
amongst all of us
to provide
hope for ukraine to provide future for
ukraine because we were discussed
discussing not only
the
here and now kind of hope but also the
future of a sovereign and free ukraine
ukraine which also
should be
given as quickly
as possible a candidate status
for to the european union i know how
important this is
for ukrainian people
to to maintain their fighting spirit
their morale
it is
extremely important we must act with the
perspective of a long distance
runner
finally
today we are faced with the question of
what can we do for ukrainians to survive
how can we help ukraine to stand on its
own feet
and a special obligation rests with
those eu countries that
have built
energy dependence on russia for years
and assault weapons to it
i won't mention any
particular member state i know that the
situation of
countries differs from one to another
but
the unity is extremely important today
and once more let me thank the european
commission and ursula for
uh your involvement to maintain this
unity and to make as
much of a progress as possible
in
yet another package of sanctions because
this is what we have to do we have to
decisively reply to all the atrocities
of war
to contribute to stop this war as
quickly as possible
today ukraine is a pillar of our world
and we all owe it a debt of gratitude
we have to start
paying it back back immediately we have
to be in solidarity because there is no
freedom without solidarity
thank you
thank you prime minister now i would
like to give the floor to the prime
minister of the kingdom of sweden madame
magdalena anderson
thank you very much and thank you
matiosh for
co hosting this conference together with
sweden and also thank you dennis and
ursula for being here with us today
and after
russia's unprovoked and unjustified
aggression against ukraine
europe is no longer the same
the testimonies from ukraine remind us
of the worst moments in european history
and we see cruelties that we hope no one
would have to experience again
and at the same time we see the courage
of ukrainian leaders and their people
not only are they fighting to protect
their own country and their lives
but ukraine is fighting for the right of
free and democratic states to choose
their own future
and in that sense you are fighting for
us all
and therefore we need to support you we
need to support you
financially militarily
uh with humanitarian aid and also we
need to continue with the sanctions and
also i'm very happy for the next section
sanction package
but as always in war civilian population
pay a high price
and this humanitarian situation in
ukraine crane is acute
and for this reason we are gathered in
warsaw here today
in solidarity with ukraine and its
people
and i'm proud of the initiative that
sweden and poland have taken together to
organize this conference
and we have succeeded in bringing actors
together that want to support ukraine
with immediate humanitarian response and
reconstruction both in the long short
and the long term
and the money that we have raised today
is desperately needed for men and women
for children and elderly who see their
lives their homes and their families
torn apart by russia's brutal war
and i happy to say that we have seemed
too far
surpassed our expectations for today's
pledge and pledging so this is a
fantastic result of this conference
we are one of many partners sweden who
work hard to further help the
people of ukraine this conference was
important today but we do need to keep
on supporting ukraine
i also want to thank our co-host uh
mateos and your government for your
leadership
to support ukraine and also thank the
polish people for your extraordinary
solidarity with millions of ukrainians
who have fled their homes
and finally as we meet here in
solidarity today we have to remind
ourselves that the reason for the
humanitarian situation in ukraine
it is the russia's war
in ukraine their aggression and russia
must end its brutal war against ukraine
and it does exist at easter solution
stop the war
go back home
today with the conference we do send a
clear message
we continue to stand with ukraine thank
you
thank you prime minister now i would
like to give the floor to the euro to
the president of the european commission
madame ursula van der laan
thank you very much and me too i want to
begin with many thanks to our hosts
magdalena and matthios
for this outstanding pledging event
and it's a wonderful opportunity and
pleasure to see you again danish mihal
prime minister of ukraine
thank you very much all of you for
making this possible
today we came together with a very clear
purpose
to support the brave people of ukraine
the ukrainians who are fighting the
aggressor
they stand up for their freedom
and we stand up for them
we are now in the tenth week of russia's
brutal invasion
10 weeks during which putin soldiers
committed atrocities
that the world cannot and will not
forget
and 10 weeks during which the european
union stood firmly with ukraine
of course we know
that we cannot match the bravery and the
sacrifices
of the people defending their country
in this fight
ukrainians pay with their lives every
day
but from day one on the european union
has stood with ukraine
indeed we have together mobilized our
economic power against russia
we introduced five waves of sanctions
that already have a devastating impact
on russia's economy and we proposed
yesterday a sixth package of sanctions
including a ban on russian oil
these sanctions are severely depleting
the russian economy
and destroying putin's warchest
putin has started this way
with this war
and he has to pay for it
on the other hand we rallied support for
our friends in ukraine
in the last 10 weeks since the beginning
of the invasion we have mobilized around
4 billion euros from the eu level to
support ukraine be it macro financial
assistance or humanitarian aid or budget
support
i want to thank from the bottom of my
heart all the people the europeans who
have opened their minds and their hearts
and their doors
to ukrainian refugees from day one on
and here especially i want to pay
tribute to the polish people who in an
amazing way have done that
it is unbelievable the solidarity this
is solidarity at its best
that we experience on a daily basis
we support these efforts with 3.5
billion that we have mobilized front
loaded for the refugees
in the european union and last month
there was a pledging here in warsaw also
with 1.8 billion for refugees within
ukraine that are in need
now today we add another
outstanding chapter
and this is this pledging conference
here congratulations to
the result this is outstanding
and i really commend you for that
we know that the next step now will have
to be
relief
and reconstruction of ukraine i'm
looking to you dennis mihal
relief because we are aware of the fact
that
the ukrainian government needs 5 billion
euros per month
to
have things
moving on paying salaries paying
pensions and
caring for the basic services
here together with our international
friends we're working to support you
but of course the big topic is the
reconstruction of ukraine hundreds of
billions of euros
and here too
with the lead of ukraine we are willing
to give the utmost and to work as
closely together with you our dream is
that we start as soon as possible with
investment
and reform so that this work will pave
the way for ukraine into the european
union many thanks
thank you madam president
i would now like to give the floor to
the prime minister of ukraine mr dennis
schmidt
dear colleagues friends partners
first of all i would like to thank
our to thank our friends from poland
sweden from european union from united
nations institutions
for organizing today's conference i want
to thank all today's participants who
came to support ukraine
this is gratitude from all the ukrainian
people for your solidarity
for for the solidarity of united europe
with ukraine
since the start of the full-scale war
our state has received more than 12
billion
u.s dollars of support in arms and
finances
and we are very grateful for this
crucial help we are currently going
through the most difficult stage of our
history when
the faith of our state is being decided
but we have
fuss
believe in victory of ukraine and
believe in a bright future believe me
ukraine and ukrainians see
that you also have this face
we have repeatedly said that ukraine's
victory will not only be on
battlefield
ukraine's victory will also
be when we become a member of european
union
a prosperous and developed country and
again without your support this will be
difficult to achieve
today i have informed my colleagues
about recovery fund and recovery plan
of ukraine we have already adopted
number of documents
and regulations that determine the basis
the funds work as well as a vision of
our
recovery
as for the fund ukraine expects that it
will be
filled for the five sources
eight from partner countries and
international financial institutions
contributions from humanitarian
organizations
donations from individuals and
corporations
and last but not least
confiscated and transferred to ukraine
russian assets
work is already underway on all these
pillars
i would like to express my gratitude to
the imf for the administrative account
as well as to the world bank for the
multi-donor trust fund they allow us to
attract funds from partner countries
today
and special thanks to the countries that
have already started to make amendments
in their own legislation so that ukraine
gets assets to russia's assets
after all the aggressor must
understand that he will have to pay for
its military actions this is crucially
important for
all of us and for the future
today i have also presented our
fundraising platform of for individu
individuals and corporations u24 wa
this platform allows you to choose one
of three areas of assistance
use a convenient payment payment method
and has a very high level of
transparency weekly updates of reports
and
the use of fund and audit by deloitte
that is why i can
that is why i call on everyone to join
us in recovery of our country
as for the recovery plan it will have
two
dimensions the first is regional
dimension
when countries cities and corporations
take the lead in recovery one of
ukrainians regions communities or cities
the second dimension is parametric this
is when national council of recovery
created the
by created by the president of ukraine
develops the parameters
of transformation in each sphere and
then together with international
partners
implements this transformation
according to the regional principle
the goal is not just to rebuild
what
has been destroyed but to build a green
modern european state
we have identified 10 key sectors and
formats for future recovery the key one
is membership in european union
also it is a development of the military
industrial complex energy independence
the regulation support for processing
and climate modernization
we are well aware of the complexity all
of these tasks and we believe that our
international friends will help us in
this us they are helping us
to defend our
and our mutual freedom now
thank you
for this and thank you again for today's
conference for support of ukraine thank
you for
unprecedented support of our country to
all of you their prime ministers their
malam president their colleagues
partners
thank you so much
thank you prime minister we are now
closing the press conference thank you
[Music]